81 ans non ça c'est l'âge que vous aurez
lorsque vous vous retrouverez ses pieds
sous terre
bon comme début de présentation j'avoue
que c'est un peu dur mais ce moment
qu'il vit c'est les statistiques stats
us et canada affirme que l'espérance de
vie du canadien moyen est de 81 ans
ces documents t-il mai mais entre vous
et moi
81 ans c'est pas juste un chiffre mais
ça l'est peut-être pour les plus jeunes
d'entre vous parce que c'est loin et
encore c'est dans le futur ça fait pas
partie de vos préoccupations immédiates
mais pour ceux qui ont 60 70 ans le
court espace temps qu'il vous reste de
commencer à faire peur mais en même
temps vous vous dites peut-être bof j'ai
eu l'occasion de vraiment avoir des
beaux accomplissements dans ma vie ici
on vous disait dès votre naissance que
vos quinze premières années de vie
serait aussi les dernières au leu pour
tout le monde c'est déstabilisant dans
ces conditions là comment on vit son
enfance qu'est ce qui nous passe par la
tête
à l'adolescence est-ce qu'on a assez de
maturité pour vraiment saisir le sens de
la vie sa valeur est ce qu'on est pressé
d'accomplir tout ce qu'on veut faire
avant de partir ou au contraire on prend
le temps de vivre le moment présent
ces deux grandes questions
existentielles et je vais vous raconter
une histoire
on est en 1973 dans une banlieue au nord
de montréal dans une famille avec trois
enfants l'aîné un garçon et les deux
plus jeunes deux fillettes qui est
maintenant un an et demi qui les sépare
entre elles la cadette est sur le point
d'avoir deux ans lorsque de gros
socialistes arrivent et découvre que les
deux filles ont une maladie héréditaire
dégénérative très sévère on dit que la
la la plus jeune elle se rendrait pas à
12 ans et que l'ordre mais peut-être
qu'elle l'affût jeunes et combative a du
caractère elle veut se rendre à 12 ans
elle atteint son objectif et le dépasse
même de une journée l'autre mais comme
elle voit sa soeur partir et qu'elle est
très consciente des statistiques à son
sujet dans sa tête il lui reste que deux
à cinq ans à vivre mais dans son coeur
dans son coeur et d'autres choses qui se
passent à 16 ans elle construire
l'ascenseur à son école parce qu'à ce
moment là elle est en fauteuil roulant
et elle n'a pas accès au deuxième étage
elle sait pas si elle va avoir la santé
pour terminer ses études mais elle fait
quand même tout ce qui est en son
pouvoir pour qui un ascenseur parce que
mais parce que c'est dans le moment
présent qu'elle en a besoin d'un et hier
c'est que d'autres après elles devront
passer
c'est pour elle son premier défi dans le
monde des adultes
sa première grande victoire et victoire
qui me touche particulièrement parce que
grâce à sa détermination
j'ai pu moi aussi fréquenté cette école
à 18 ans et comment son implication
sociale dans l'espérance organismes dans
la défense de droits
dans la vingtaine et se marient fait son
entrée à l'université
ce divorce ou si c'est une fille comme
les autres quand même elle devient aussi
présidente fondatrice d'un organisme qui
construit et gère des logements adaptés
avec service 24 heures sur 24 dans la
trentaine et prend son sac à dos voyage
à travers le monde
nicaragua belgique allemagne france
vancouver guadeloupe il y aura beaucoup
de frontières qu'il arrête dans la
quarantaine elle revient chez elles se
déposent devient conférencière pour
inspirer les gens à créer leur vie au
lieu de la subir
et aujourd'hui elle est avec nous je
vais vous la présentez sur l'écran je
vous demande de les accueillir très
chaleureusement
madame béatrice martel
je vais bien humeur alors mais béatrice
et ma grand mère y en a peut-être pas
mais vous qui avez deviné que c'est mon
histoire que je vous ai raconté
mais ce que vous devinez pas c'est
comment j'ai fait pour dépasser autant
les statistiques et avoir une vie aussi
remplie épanouie
si vous ne savez pas c'est sûr moi non
plus je sais pas non non non mais c'est
vrai j'aimerais ça j'aimerais ça vous
divulguez ma recette secrète pour que
vous puissiez vous aussi dépassé les 7
fugué et et vivre c'est pourquoi vous
êtes nous sur terre mais je détiens port
le secret ce que je peux vous partagez
ce sont mes réflexions mes découvertes
le regard que j'ai porté sur moi et sur
ce qui m'entoure vous savez quand on
quand on est enfin on est en lien direct
avec son être ce qui nous en éloigne
c'est lorsque les adultes nous inculque
leurs façons de faire et de voir quand
j'étais jeune j'étais très conscient de
ma condition physique évidemment je peux
pas le cacher a fait c'est très visible
et je connaissais aussi la raison de mon
incarnation j'avais pas les mots pour
l'expliquer évidemment mais
intérieurement je savais les médecins et
les étrangers avec leurs commentaires
auraient pu me déstabiliser et même le
programme et à n'être rien d'autre
qu'une maladie mais c'est pas ce qui est
arrivé
ce poste est arrivé parce que j'ai pas
permis que ça arrive je me rappelle
quand on quand on faisait des les
sorties de famille
les étrangers à bord des régulièrement
mes parents et leur disait
à quel point je faisais pissier c'était
de valeur ils se demandaient qu'est ce
que j'étais pour faire plus tard moi
quand j'entends des sages avaient juste
envie d'une chose de leur rentrer dedans
avec mon fauteuil roulant non mais qui
était vrai je n'ai jamais fait j'étais
beaucoup trop timides et trop poli pour
le faire mais dans ma tête je me gèle
les pots pour leur vie ce que je pensais
je portais des lunettes dans ce malheur
je fais pitié mais non mais non c'est
vous qui faites si vous me regardez même
pas vous voyez juste mon fauteuil
roulant vous par là les parents comme si
je n'existais pas je suis intelligente
je capable de vous entendre
ouais je marche pour tout un pays après
que ce fait ce que je marche pour moi je
sais que je peux capable vous faites
pitié parce que lorsque vous êtes tout
croche ans dans puis vous voulez même
pas le voir
c'est pour ça que vous me voyez pas
j'existe woippy j'ai un avenir
moi je sais ce que je vais faire plus
tard je vais écrire des livres
je vais faire des conférences partout à
travers le monde parce que j'ai des
choses à vous dire mais je sais pas
encore quoi parce que je trouve sur mes
mais je sais que je vais avoir des
choses à vous dire
elle savait ou à s'en aller l'accident
j'ai jamais laisser les autres
déterminer ma vie que ce soit les grands
spécialistes avec leurs connaissances
les étrangers avec leur méconnaissance
ou même mes parents qui ont vu leur
fille enfourché nollet johnson alors que
je suis même pas capable d'être assis
tout seul sur une planète mais je pense
que ce qui a été le plus difficile pour
mes parents c'est pas le handicap mais
c'est ma liberté d'esprit si j'avais si
j'avais un ingrédient de mars est à vous
donner ce serait celui-ci
mettre l'accent sur ses forces mon
effort cela les exploiter au maximum
c'est sur elle que je me suis assise
monde rudas mon leadership mais la
facilité de communiquer mon mon désir du
dépassement de la découverte mais
surtout la capacité de voir au delà des
limites
ce sont mes forces qui m'ont fait
avancer ce sont mes forces qui m'ont
permis de créer ma vie et justement en
parlant de création j'ai une dernière
anecdote à vous raconter est ce que vous
me permettez de la raconter je sur ok
merci il ya quelques années
j'attendais le monde transports j'étais
sur le trottoir d'entrain tricoter
tranquillement comme je le fais souvent
en public
une femme qui passe devant moi qui
s'arrête et qui me dit si vous avez
trouvé une belle façon de passer tant de
passer le temps je les regardais et je
lui répondu le temps je le pense pas je
le vis et la vie je la subis pas je l'a
créé je sais pas combien de temps il me
reste encore aviv jeu pour besoin de
vous dis ce que je pense de statistiques
mais une chose que je sais c'est que
l'espace temps c'est pas important ce
qui importe c'est ce qu'on fait avec